pallets are available at most building
suppliers this particular uh group came
from uh a plumbing supply outfit nearby
here this the back pallet is about 8 ft
long probably used transport bathtubs or
something like this these ones are
normal 4T X
4T I stand one up on either end and two
in the middle and that gives me three
bins you might need someone to help help
you hold them still while you complete
this phase plain old bailing wire ready
readily uh available at the hardware
store just Loop it
through twist
it and then with a pair of pliers or
Nippers just tighten it right
up snip that off grab a hold of it pull
it tight and then twist it just twist
till it won't go anymore if you keep
twisting it'll break it but if you break
it just get another piece of wire wire's
cheap okay cut off the Loose Ends so
there's nothing sharp and tap that down
continue that that way through the other
four pallets you can do it top and
bottom and there you have your
uh practically free three bin composter